it's actually the very first fat con is
it just gonna be a massive food haul
that would be sick that'd be cool is
lizzo performing
[Music]
oh you guys are gonna be excited about
this uh in October Temple University is
set to uh be the venue
for a very interesting event is it is it
Halloween Fright Night
Elon Musk versus Mark Zuckerberg that'd
be cool no it's the it's actually the
very first fat con oh what's back on
what is that and how do we get in is it
just gonna be a massive food haul that
would be sick that'd be cool
is lizzo performing a massive food yeah
like like six to six Night Market but
they call it the fat convention and it's
like just nothing but [__] what is fat
con what would fact you know what's
crazy is that some of the vendors that
would make the most sense so this is the
very first of its kind there's never
been like a fat people convention Lane
Bryant but
right wouldn't it be though come on what
that's not mean I'm not gonna say much
but I feel like I've been to facton
before
I go to fatcon all the time it's 2 A.M
at Walmart it's the county fair already
no so it's funny because the first time
I read about this camera I read about it
on like a site that was like super
hating on it yeah um and the way they
described it was like it just looked
like a bunch of fat people getting
together and being happy that they're
fat it's a safe space for right and it
is it is a safe space why is that why
are you gonna hate on anything you can
hate people alone like I get the whole
body positivity [__] it's like funny to
like hate on but this is actually good
this is a great [__] show part of
it's funny to hate on
this is why do you get it no there's not
even something hateable you can enjoy
this it's just Community right wait what
do you mean you even know what happens
here yet
I want to be can we guess can we all be
in a convention where it's a bunch of
fat people okay
it's pH fat just go just to be around
just go to Comic-Con
but there's also hot girls in Cosplay
now and that's yeah
and you know what the guys were
complaining non-stop I don't like that I
liked it when it was real Comics yeah
missed him the LG Comic-Con
for all these [__] coming through
with [__] point two percent body fat
hate it ruined it it all dressed like
Rogue too I hate her my least favorite
character so yeah it's
um so the when I first read it it
sounded so bad and then now I'm reading
it from like the opposite point of view
and it I could see the intention behind
it is good it's a place like you said
it's a safe space it's more of a
conference where they're gonna have lots
of different speeches and a lot of it's
supposed to boost your mental health as
a person with like an overweight box
[Laughter]
what were you picturing
how did we survive till August this is
it dude have you guys been to Fremont
Street August is not over yet okay
there's a restaurant there I think it's
called heart attack or something how's
that Grill there's a [__] scale
outside if you weigh more than 300
pounds you eat for free wow they embrace
the [__] fat they're like you know
what
[__] all these diets [__] all that [__]
you come here and you eat and there are
so many fat [__] that go to this
restaurant it is one of the best places
in America because I like to me I like
unapologetically fat this whole [__]
body positivity I'm sorry it's like
they're trying to be like oh we're
[__] this too but we couldn't live
our normal lives being fat too that [__]
is like fake fat real fat to me is like
you go to the [__] Diner and you
order for a family of five but it's for
yourself yeah and you're just like going
down so you think that people preaching
body positivity are all a bunch of
posers and they're not the real fat like
hell no dude oh let's deal with our
mental health and then but all these
guys are just like dude they're like
yeah I don't need no [__] therapist
I'm fat I love food
so there is it physicization
to uh
to sit there and watch a fat chick eat a
lot and like be into it yeah oh I don't
like girls eating food I like that might
be fine I like watching people eat food
though me too like guys or girls they
just guys or girls you're bi that way
huh
I just like food in general and it gets
my penis harder than that
no I hit friend a friend named named
Shawna Malcolm and she told me
that she's a bigger chick right and she
was telling me that guys she would have
to like suss out certain guys because
they would want to watch her eat and
then she's like this is kind of weird
because like you you're clearly here to
watch me eat yeah just eat with me dude
what's her name maybe I don't know tons
of money doing that
um what's her name she was she was on
um uh uh she's the big girl that's
always into controversy you're her
friend oh he's talking about not her
friend the H3 yeah yeah the girl that
worked with H3 yeah yeah she's blonde uh
yeah she was making a [__] on only
fans I think eating food naked or
whatever but or whatever she's just
really good at finding she's a troll
though she's a professional but it's a
whole fetish stupid yeah she's a really
smart person she's really good but she
comes across a certain way obviously as
a blonde and she plays it the [__] up
she plays like one of her best videos
she ever did was like where she's like I
endorse Mitt Romney for president and
like it meets he got destroyed by the
whole internet and like nothing drove
views for her more like that's the thing
like she's really really smart but as
someone who plays on the fat fetish
thing yes right
and uh I don't know what I just I I
don't know why this whole thing is like
Hey fat people are beautiful too like
whatever like I'm like what does that
have to do with loving food and just
like I don't know I never saw them as
not beautiful I didn't think they were
sexualized
I thought like fit people are sexualize
I think we should sexualize bigger
people more I think they are sexualized
by they are people it's just you know
maybe not the mainstream mainstream
common doesn't physicization get some
people laid a little bit more I think so
I think it does help but also because
there's chubby chasers there's
definitely in my opinion go get your bag
with a fat con if you were to throw a
fidcon if you were to throw a skinny con
if you were to throw a Comic-Con what
you know what I mean it's just like yeah
I think any car that's cool there's a
bunch of like-minded people that's cool
that's a demographic how about this how
about this yeah I've never not been to a
fat con
yeah that's true I think it is America
just gathering in general places yo
America does have a lot of fat [__]
though do you think that's what
Europeans laugh about when they come
here they're like there are so many
[__] fat [__] if you're hella fit in
your skinny villain you show up to
fatcon is that like an issue can we add
a can we add a fat [__] counter at the
bottom well no here's the thing here's
the thing if this was like 100 years ago
yeah all these fat people everyone will
just go they're rich yeah no yeah that's
fair to say they'll be like oh he's well
off did you know there was a fat
Gentleman's Club
let's look it up so sick to be a part of
I mean you had to be a certain weight
they're and then all of it it's just
like modern day
no this is like the [__] Great
Depression era oh if you're fat in the
Great Depression
for you brother yeah yeah
but they all look like the Monopoly
dudes they're fat as [__] wearing top
hats and cigars and [__] and it was like
a men's club
entertain us
the objective of this Con is really to
sort of
um almost like counteract the negative
effects of fat phobia by providing
different sources for how they can be
confident go happy and you know just
mentally healthy like I actually read it
I was like oh I get it yeah it's cool
but then there was details
I thought they were gonna have like all
right so like you know you have a guy
that's like 400 pounds or whatever and
or like what's that one show that the
there was the two big girls my my 800
pound life or whatever oh the two big
girls the 600 pound life I paid my bills
my
yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah my huge time life I think
yeah anything like that I think one of
them passed her her husband her husband
they recently got married and all that
and until like I was thinking like maybe
like the biggest ones are the are the
leaders and then it's like a Convention
of like that means they're changing
their leaders who's the biggest who's
the biggest yeah yeah yeah yeah who's
the biggest one who can lead us right
and then there's like there's like a
hierarchy
the biggest is the baddest
who has the ability to lead us so the
thing I thought was weird is they get on
the scale for the uh event there's like
a headlining um speaker like the lead
the person that they all want to see
talk right and uh maybe I have to read
more into this to figure it out but it's
it's a person called sonali rashitor and
it says that they're the fat sex
therapist and one of their focuses is
that they talk about the um how fat
phobia has white supremacist ideals
Jesus Christ why not a thing doesn't
everything every I think that's the easy
that phobia has white supremacist ideas
that's too many vocabulary words for me
don't grocery bag handles have white
supremacist Origins everything has white
supremacy words
what the [__] what the f but the fat
guys Club I could have sworn had no
black folks it was just a it was a bunch
of Rich fat white guys if this took
place that far back if it was any kind
of Club
that's true they're white supremacists
yeah the grocery bag handle but yeah I
thought that was kind of interesting
that's just a lot that's just my
Supremacy it's rooted in in fat wait fat
phobias being afraid of fat people dude
fat phobia is also worldwide it's hard
to be afraid of fat people they're so
the user the use of the of the phobia I
think is kind of out of place in today's
society everyone attaches everything
phobia means an irrational illogical
fears yeah yeah I don't think any of us
are afraid of we're afraid
yeah
that's that would be okay I used to be
scared because everyone was like yeah
big people are gonna sit on you and you
can't [__] it you're gonna suffocate and
now you should save that to you you
never heard that in elementary school
yeah all the time someone else
threatened you on their behalf yeah for
sure no they'll be like you see that
they're gonna they're gonna sit on you
like if you're a bad boy that big
person's gonna sit on you yeah yeah I've
heard that before your mama so fat she's
young
[Laughter]
your mama's so fat a buzz hit her and
she was like who threw that rock yeah
yeah that's funny that's fat that's
Throwbacks that's a big chick or like uh
your mom's a fat she she irons her jeans
in the driveway that's fine yeah that's
I like that one that's probably my
favorite why are you looking like that
bro
stop it how dare you dude [__] look
at me with respect
your mom is so big she was the keynote
speaker
[Music]